[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau 7,8 écossais tu étais qu
dédié ce soir à l'agriculture les
yvelines c'est le plus grand département
agricole de l'île de france ouest
c'est aussi le deuxième département
superficie derrière la seine et marne
vous voulez en savoir plus voici le
sommaire nous débuterons l'émission avec
un zoom sur le premier démonstrateur de
l'agriculture urbaine de france les
ferments ville de saint cyr l'école le
but rapprocher des habitants de
l'agriculture nous ferons ensuite un
pont avec l'entreprise self eden la
start-up perd nos agriculteurs via son
application de gérer son exploitation en
temps réel un gain de temps et d'argent
pour les entrepreneurs et puis nous
recevrons jérôme regnault céréaliers à
plaisir et membre de la fdsea
nous apporterons les problèmes liés à
l'agriculture sur le territoire mais
tout d'abord faisons un point sur
l'agriculture sur le territoire
l'agriculture représente 14 % du
territoire soit plus de 1000 35 hectares
cultivés avec plus de 17 exploitations
agricoles c'est un territoire propice à
la culture grâce à un seul lit mono
habchi le un climat clément et des
précipitations favorable la grande
majorité des agriculteurs du territoire
cultive des céréales et oléoprotéagineux
selon une étude de l'agglomération
n'assistera dans cinq à dix ans à un
changement de génération dans le monde
agricole et cela a déjà commencé avec la
ferme en ville de saint cyr c'est le
premier démonstrateur d'agriculture
urbaine de france
les particuliers peuvent même louer des
parcelles pour avoir leur propre potager
regardez imaginez une ancienne décharge
transformée en ferme
c'est le pari un peu fou mais réussie de
l'association le vivant et la ville en
2014 elle a créé le premier
démonstrateur d'agriculture urbaine de
france c'est un démonstrateur parce que
ça a une vocation d'être dupliqué sur
d'autres sites délaissé la particularité
c'est que tout est hors sol par nature
même des sols qui sont qui sont pollués
ou contraint toutes les technologies
agricoles sont développés au dessus du
sol
là vous ou situé dans la zone de
production et ont produit des fraises
des framboises et tomates cerises qu'on
va ensuite en circuit court et c'est
l'intérêt de faire des fermes en ville
c'est de pouvoir alimenter l'ensemble
des populations qui vivent aujourd'hui
la plupart du temps en ville une
ancienne friche de près de 4 hectares
devenu un jardin d'éden
l'hiver les équipes préparent les beaux
jours ils viennent d'aménager la culture
des fraises se fit là il vient protéger
des insectes bien protégé du vent il a
pas mal de fonctions thermique mais on a
décidé de réinstaller c'est la première
fois qu'on le fasse cette année un
tunnel plastique dessous pour gagner en
précocité et pour
commencer plus tôt dans la saison
avantage du hors sol l'eau qui n'est pas
absorbée par les plantes et récupérer
pour être réinjectés une économie non
négligeable pour cette denrée précieuse
les particuliers peuvent aussi jouer les
apprentis maraîchers depuis 2015 la
ferme en ville s'est lancée dans la
location de jardin si vous souhaitez
louer un jardin vous disposez d'un
morceau de cabanes ou d'une malle en
fonction de l'option vous prenez et
ensuite 50 mètres carrés vous avez deux
bacs et demi cela correspond à peu près
à 25 mètres carrés de culture avec un
cours de jardinage par mois une
irrigation automatique qui vous enlève
l'astreinte de l'arrosage ce qui est en
soi un confort qui n'est pas du tout
négligeable
vous cultivez hors sol du coup vous êtes
en hauteur vous avez moins de à vous
laisser et c'est une manière de
sensibiliser le grand public
depuis deux saisons l'intérêt des
citadins pour ce dispositif se manifeste
de plus en plus aujourd'hui 50 % des
abonnés vient de saint germain en laye
boulogne même paris on pense que
l'avenir de l'agriculture urbaine
ce sera probablement une filière
multifonctionnel associer des métiers
qui sont complémentaires
à voir à la fois des métiers de service
comme typiquement la location de jardin
et des métiers de production comme ce
qu'on voit ici autour de nous une zone
qui est dédiée à la production
professionnelle pour ensuite vendre
cette production pour pouvoir fournir
les urnes en circuit court
chaque année la ferme en ville crée des
emplois saisonniers pour s'occuper des
cultures elles produites en moyenne 12 à
13 tonnes de fruits et légumes par an
elle espère arriver à 18h dans quelques
années
alors quelle est la situation de
l'agriculture périurbaine sur le
territoire pour en savoir plus nous
avons interviewé jérôme regnault membres
de la fdsea et c'est réaliste à plaisir
écoutez le dites moi aujourd'hui c'est
compliqué pour un jeune agriculteur de
s'installer
oui aujourd'hui c'est assez compliqué
surtout dans ma filière qui est calé
filière de céréales d'une part on sort
d'une année particulièrement difficile
2016 on l'a vu sur le climat sur tous
les objets mais l'agriculture était
directement impactés donc depuis 30 40
ans a été l'année la plus difficile
qu'on ait connu c'est la première fois
où
l'exploitation je veux dire entre
guillemets assez confortable comme la
mienne faisait du déficit
donc pour un jeune qui s'installe et se
lancer sadc difficile ensuite c'est
aussi le cadre des exploitations
familiales est en train de tout
doucement s'étioler disparaître ça
sollicitent toute une famille de
s'installer quand les frères et soeurs
font pas ce choix là faut quand même
qu'on pensait que ces jeunes ont plongé
donc c'est pas facile et même un jeune
qui a la passion qui est l'énergie
ça va lui demander un tel investissement
etc que démarrer aujourd'hui c'est très
très dur faut vraiment localement lui
faire confiance
oh non pas nos structures pas
professionnel on suit on organise un
moyen parcours la salle actions etc
donc ils sont conseillés la descente de
gestion très pointue dans la profession
agricole quelles sont les aides qui peut
avoir pour s'installer alors directement
et vous avez des aides de projets
surtout de l'accompagnement la chambre
d'agriculture les centres de gestion
plus financièrement après localement par
une agglomération par la région etc
oui voilà aujourd'hui saint quentin par
exemple réfléchit beaucoup à promouvoir
ce qu'on appelle l'agriculture de
proximité s'est vu leur courte
exactement remettre les filières courtes
au contact le plus possible ce mouvement
de réflexion qui nous amène aujourd'hui
à nous dire que on va entretenir par
l'économie agricole 90% du paysage
puisqu'il le paysage c'est avant tout il
est avant tout maintenu parce que
économiquement elle arrive à vivre de
notre métier mais qu'on va pouvoir
peut-être sur 10 % notre parcellaire
restant aller chercher ces filières
courtes à les développer des choses au
contact et c'est pour aller chercher
vraiment de la valeur ajoutée à notre
métier et puis pouvoir équilibrer
l'ensemble parce qu'on est de plus en
plus au prix coûtant
chaque année avec le script hume 50 ans
souhaite faire émerger de nombreuses
startups et dans cette ruche
d'entreprises il y à celle fedene
positionner sur l'agriculture connectés
et lauréat du concours pour l'innovation
organisé par le territoire regardez
avec 60% de la population qui vivra en
zone urbaine en 2030 et en 2050 9
milliards de personnes à nourrir une
problématique se pose pour y répondre il
ya l'émergence de l'agriculture urbaine
qui est en hausse et les deux associés
compte mettre à profit leurs boîtiers
pour aider la population
notre boîtier est principalement conçu
pour tout ce qui est l'agriculture hors
sol c'est-à-dire que donc tout ce qui
est n'est pas en plein champ très
clairement ça regarde en fait t'es
paramètres impactant dans l'eau comme le
ph l'électro conductique mettrie
l'oxygène dissous et dans l'air comme la
température l'hygrométrie le co2 et à
partir de ces infos nous permet d'aider
à la défaire de l'aide à la décision sur
comment mieux cultiver optimiser sa
culture optimiser sa culture la
possibilité de gérer cette culture en
temps réel où que vous soyez grâce au
boîtier et à une application qui vous
alerte si vous devez agir sur celle ci
un procédé que les deux associés de self
eden souhaite utiliser à la ferme de
gally à saint cyr l'école grâce à notre
solution au monitorat on continue
l'environnement de culture et pourront
détecter un paramètre qui dérive ou un
manque d'eau et pouvoir dire aux
professionnels d'un venir sur site pour
rétablir se soucier self et dance ou et
ensuite étendre son projet à la région
parisienne et pourquoi pas en france
aussi alors quel est l'avenir de
l'agriculture périurbaine et surtout
comment l'agglomération les soutiens on
écoute
jérôme regnault quels sont vos échanges
et lien avec l'agglomération est ce que
vos produits sont réutilisés dans les
cantines de la vie
et c'est parce que - et en céréales tout
sa part sur le marché commun il ya une
sensibilité bien sûr à maintenir ces
agriculteurs qui sont d'accord un suivi
son arrivée oui par exemple sur une
commune comme plaisir nous devrons être
encore 3 s'est rallié plus quelques
spécialisés mais on sait reliques il
fait bon effectivement leur travail je
suis le dernier les autres sous traitent
leurs leur travail donc si vous voulez
je pense que il a eu cette prise de
conscience
saint-quentin donc et la commune de
plaisir on vraiment cette sensibilité de
dire qu'il faut maintenir l'agriculture
en cherchant des solutions c'est ça
notre histoire c'est que ça l'était
encore une commune comme plaisir va
arriver à 35000 habitants
mais la plus grande partie de son
territoire et agricoles et forestiers
donc c'est comme une réalité je pense
que c'est un confort c'est un paysage
pour chacun donc c'est d'importance puis
quelque part même si on a tous un avis
sur la culture
j'aime espérait encore que les gens
aiment encore leurs agriculteurs aux
plats de chez eux aiment les connaître
c'est plus agréable plutôt que d'avoir
un industriel à ses pieds d'avoir
quelqu'un qui est là pour rendre service
pour discuter avoir du temps passé et
c'est parce que ses atouts dans la balle
aujourd'hui un agriculteur gagne environ
combien ce que c'est encore rentable
alors là la moyenne 2016 en france est
passé de sous les 350 euros mensuels
d'accord moi pour être honnête en 2016
j'ai fait du négatif c'est à dire que
j'ai pu en ayant la chance d'avoir une
structure assez solide de tenir un peu
de foncier d'être propriétaire encore de
mon matériel etc
allez à la trésorerie voile - banques
aient la chance aussi d'avoir souvent
d'être dans le milieu mutualiste en
agriculture en leur expliquant qu'il me
fallait trois ans pour me refaire en
trésorerie et donc ça s'est pas mal
passé on est reparti comme ça sur un sur
un court terme mais globalement
aujourd'hui vous avez un prix mondial
d'une tonne de blé qui se promène entre
160 170 euros
d'accord vous enlever 20 euros avant que
ce soit payé à l'agriculteur
et nos coûts de revient se promène entre
125 et 130 euros l'hectare aujourd'hui
donc rapidement les deux se rapprochent
vous comprenez un petit peu la verchère
jour merci merci à vous et tout de suite
on passe à l'agenda micro-entrepreneurs
comment démarrer votre activité
grâce à cet atelier vous allez apprendre
à comprendre le régime juridique
le régime social spécifique les régimes
fiscaux et la responsabilité juridique
du créateur c'est le lundi 3 juillet de
9h30 à 11h30 au ski cube à guyancourt
et puis toujours au ski cube un autre
atelier vous proposera chef d'entreprise
comment protéger vos données et votre
patrimoine
vous l'apprendrez lors d'un atelier le
vendredi 7 juillet de 9h30 à 12h
l'animation sera organisée par un
référent de la dgsi du ministère de
l'intérieur
j'espère que vous en savez plus sur
l'agriculture sur le territoire c'est la
fin de ce set 8 échos merci de nous
avoir suivis et surtout bonne soirée
[Musique]